well I lived through a flood back in 92
there was a nor'easter in Jersey which
[ __ ] it predicated clerks actually it
came right before we're gonna start
shooting clerks in December this
nor'easter happened flooded my whole
town my house is underwater like at one
point man like they evacuated everybody
and they were like yeah I got a house my
mom might have her leaving so but we had
cats and I didn't want to leave him in
the house because it's still hip deep
and water and [ __ ] so come stay here
with the cats and some candles and after
everybody left ten minutes after they
left I was just like what a bad idea
this work it just seems so noble I
thought my mother be like leave the
cat's come with us and you know make a
fuss or something like that nobody
fought me okay see totally though like
what a good guy by Tiger I was in there
unplugging like on the couch and the
water was yay high and the cats were all
around me looking at me like aren't you
gonna do something about this and
bugging all their Friskies food is flown
by and it blowed up like this big and I
was also win for them Oh huge man but
they didn't dare not go near it I found
that couch that night and I said they're
going [ __ ] my life this [ __ ] sucks
and you never thought you'd get anything
back together again at [ __ ] FEMA
wonderful agency the government runs
Federal Emergency Management agencies
that come in they start divvying out
giving out some cash for houses for lost
vehicles and [ __ ] like that so me and
Muse we didn't own any property except
my parents did they got a little money
for their house thankfully they were
insured as well but me and Muse we had
these two cars she's two Volkswagens a
Volkswagen Rabbit Volkswagen Beetle and
the beetle we were driving because we
were fix up the ratah once the rabbit
was fixed we were gonna [ __ ] it sell the
beetle and use that as our car we shared
a carcass we lived a block and a half
away from each other so the night of the
flood we're starting to get warnings
like they did for Sandy and the hot cars
are at my house in my driveway and [ __ ]
not unlike Jason uses he was counting
irresponsible and should know the heck
you say I'm not kidding so we're getting
the calls you know everyone's like amen
the storms are coming this year though
we live downtown in Highlands which is
actually below sea level
we even when it's dry so Muse calls me
up because hey man I'm hearing like lots
to talk about we should move the cars
for the storm and I said dude it never
floods here man just leave them on my
drive while you're out of your mind
go to sleep click woke up in the morning
my cars
we're just underwater there were two the
two vaults hugs I remember I told him
use that night I was like don't even if
it flooded dude
Volkswagens are airtight good night I
looked out the window man they were just
full of [ __ ] water so those cars man
when FEMA came through means is like
let's file for the cars we had a couple
cars and they cost us 400 bucks total
there's like 150 for the beetle and then
they were 250 for the rabbit and [ __ ]
and we was working on they were busted
up that's why they're so cheap 400 bucks
- I was like dude they're not gonna give
us 400 I was like what if they did
wouldn't it be amazing I was a guy how
this will go down we go down Borough
Hall we fill out the paperwork I was
like put his name on it because I didn't
[ __ ] believe this [ __ ] for a second
mm-hmm
we left I was like we will never hear
from those [ __ ] again do you
understand me never you know [ __ ] it two
weeks later news cause up he goes I have
a check in my hand
what come what's going on man he goes
they gave me [ __ ] to check before
that goes they gave us Blue Book value
for the cars man I was like what we told
them the cars only cost us 400 matter
they go by the guide so they gave us
4,000 bucks so he'll use $4,000 and now
thankfully was a good guy wasn't like
they gave it to me [ __ ] you fat boy yeah
be broken have a Jinni one got himself a
new vehicle he's like what are you gonna
do with your half I said I'm gonna put
it in a clerks and so that was kind of
the seed money that got me going I just
think I'm sorry before we move on um it
Donna me you're the worst person in the
world to be with in a disaster every
state every mist every decision you made
was a bad one during that story I was
just thinking about that [ __ ] cars
you don't move the cars [ __ ] that you
leave them in the driveway they get
flooded they tell you to leave the house
you stay in the house with [ __ ] cats
on a soggy couch watching
whisker lickin's float by with the
[ __ ] cats bad idea - no dude I myself
give you money you say [ __ ] that they're
gonna give us money and let news put his
on the paperwork brother gets $4,000
you're a horrible [ __ ] person to be
around in a disaster you're [ __ ]
useless I would like to address all
three of those points what was the first
one the personal is what you let the
cars go underwater because you did want
to move them because all they're fair
enough folks packets are airtight you
were thinking Lindsay Lohan and it's an
automobile in 1991 Lindsay Lohan was
poor and she was airtight I'm very
serious but it was like it was like
pacifiers or something i just but i
guarante umber one good sir
I I couldn't let muse take the cars
because as previously said he was
[ __ ] irresponsible as opposed to the
guy who let them get drowned in water
nobody knew I was irresponsible till
bang oh alright number two I stayed home
with a catch yes but I'm all about the
[ __ ] what was number three you let me
use put his name on the paperwork that
netted him $4,000 could have potentially
screwed you on that money if he wasn't
nice enough to cut you in
yeah but that was maybe it was a test of
character maybe was a test of
intelligence and you fail
[Music]
you
[Music]